good afternoon everyone today I'm going
to talk to you about securing websites
in the early web and telling you a few
funny stories about people having their
days profoundly ruined before I start
I'm Kati underscore friend on Twitter
please tell me what you think about your
talks because love getting feedback from
people and just in case moving images or
videos on big screens makes you feel
secure and comfortable content warning
will appear on the bottom right hand
corner of my slides so hi I'm Katie I
work for M p.m. come and see me later on
but if you want a sticker I've got lots
of wombat stickers please come and say
hello and I just wanted to shout out
something I'm really passionate about
I love volunteering at Scotland Jay s if
you fancy coming to a conference that is
there and you can walk up a mountain
during your lunch break and have a walk
in the National Park that is exactly
where our venue is it's really beautiful
you should totally come along and get
yourself a ticket anyway I came to the
web like a lot of people through fandom
if you were here and what you watched
Rachel wait to talk keeping means and
that weird last year you'll know exactly
what I'm talking about so friends meet
other fans through forms through web
forms where you can log-in and distain
stay up until the early hours of the web
just discussing your favorite characters
and post signatures used to be a very
common site you used to use them to
share your fandom and show off your
skills they're aware of creatively
expressing yourself and from many they
were an introduction into web design and
development this is how I learned HTML
you could add them to your posts by
writing HTML it was also my first
introduction to messing with other
people's sites and you could do things
like HTML bombs HTML bombs is where you
deliberately or accidentally
technically it's folks like it
excellent okay Randall polls for the
tech support people
[Music]
so you could mismatch HTML and create
HTML bombs and this was accidental at
first but lots of lots of people used it
deliberately and maliciously to insert
mismatched HTML to make content
disappear off the side of the screens or
make it completely unreadable all
together this is caused by writing code
that trusts any old crap that the user
sends you this is otherwise known as bad
input validation there was another forum
around about this time dedicated to the
animal crossing games and animal
crossing if you've not played it before
is Ana Dilek game filled with a town of
peaceful people just getting along and
trading is a really lovely a Dilek game
but this forum had a page that allowed
you to edit your profile change your
user name change your password and
someone discovered that there is a
hidden input field that contained the
user ID of the person's profile that
you're editing so someone thought what
happens if I change that ID to the owner
of that forum make it user ID 1 and
change the password they found it that
found out that they could edit the
profile of any user on this forum
needless to say this website devolved
into utter anarchy for a few days until
it was fixed there aren't any rules of
making web development but if there were
I'd make this one the first rule never
trust user input never ever trust user
input always ask yourself how even the
nicest people playing the nicest game in
the universe can misuse your code for
fun and profit because they will so how
can you help protect yourself against
bad input validation when you use the
library like joy to validate your back
your data on the back end to make sure
that the data is exactly what it appears
to be make sure it's the right type and
the right length
you can check your users actions against
the identity as well to check what
actions that they can take and whose
data they can take it on for instance it
shouldn't be possible for a newly
registered user to change the profile of
the owner of the form as we just saw and
never ever rely on client-side
validation alone
it is a convenience to the user and
absolutely nothing else it's not a
security measure
for my next story many forums on the
early web allowed you to log in using a
login form just like this so you could
enter your username and your password
and everything save you from having to
enter these every time you wanted to
make a new post many of these forms are
a venerable to an attack using this one
neat password you could log in as any
user that you chose this attack allows
users to run their own database queries
on your site which is otherwise known as
SQL injection when you fill out a
username and a password in a login form
like this the credentials submitted in
these forms get filled into an SQL query
that you can see on the right SQL is a
popular language for querying databases
and this example checks users matching a
username and a password if the database
find matching users it grants the user
permission to log in let's see what
happens to the query if you submit that
one weird password the database has
interpreted them as regular SQL which
has a consequence that we didn't expect
this part of the query says give me all
the users with username matching these
name admin and password all one equals
one this is like saying to the query
this is like saying to the database
this makes the query match every single
user in the database but the software is
checking from more than zero matches so
it grants the user permissions to log in
this is essentially saying to the
database give me all the users matching
these name admin or whatever you got I
guess I'm not fussy SQL injection hands
the keys of the database to your users
allows attackers to extraordinary access
to your website
to recover sensitive information of your
users and to give themselves complete
control to your site one of the most
famous examples of SQL injection was
Drupal Gaiden it affected every single
Drupal 7 website underneath that version
number if you think about how many use
of how many sites use Drupal that has a
lot of sites allowed remote code
execution which allows the attacker full
control over the website there's also
some evidence suggests that tack has
patched the original exploit after
breaching sites to make it appear as if
those sites have not been had not been
breached so how can you help protect
yourself against text SQL injection
don't use spring for a concatenation to
build queries get some help from things
like tools that offer you parameterize
Prairie's such as PDO and connects and
or you can use object relational mapping
to get expert help from experienced tool
maintainer x' who've done this before I
wanted to tell a quick bonus story that
has nothing to do with the web it
relates to a game that I used to play
called world of warcraft in world of
warcraft you can take home
big big big bosses big monsters and some
once someone found that by shooting a
fireball and running away and shooting a
fireball and running away they could tow
a bus across the continent
to the capital city of Stormwind so they
managed to get this boss called log
Kazak into storm and and look Kazik when
he kills a character he heals himself
and his maximum HP increases within a
few hours of being in Stormwind look as
AK was fundamentally immortal and the
blizzard the makers of the game had to
roll the server's back in order to
restore people's accounts this is a
really good example of how you may not
need to breach a computer system in
order to recover
another story about my time on Final
Fantasy forums was when I was browsing
the site I was just looking at
conversations about whether certain
characters were resurrect or off and
suddenly I was locked out I was
presented with the login screen and I
just thought what's going home and this
wasn't just happening to me this was
happening to other people as well so I
wondered what was causing this
we eventually tracked it down to one
user with a broken avatar we thought
what's going on well it turns out that
they'd set the avatar to logout dot PHP
so that any user who's looking at this
site would be logged out
this isn't app that gets other users to
do your dirty work for you
just otherwise known as cross-site
request forgery
while CSRF four-shot cross-site request
forgery was successfully exploited on
the Netflix website and this isn't the
Netflix that we have today this is the
old Netflix that used to post you DVDs
in order to watch at home
this attack was possible without even
injecting any content into the Netflix
website in fact you could host this
attack on your site and just convince
people to go to that site I mean oh
that's possible because how many times
is this happen to you
so what if you could convince people to
go to your website and what if those
people were logged into Netflix in 2006
Dave Ferguson discovered a cross-site
request forgery in Netflix of a mobility
and Netflix to sprinkle to put an image
with that URL that URL adds a film of
his choice to this users cue sprinkle in
a few requests to change the account
name and to change the shipping address
and you could ship yourself free DVDs
courtesy of whoever looked at your
website cross-site request forgery
exploits the trust placed in users
browsers why shouldn't Netflix trust
these requests they come from legitimate
users the users have the right cookies
and they locked him themselves the
problem stems from trusting user
sessions and trusting cookies on their
own so how can you help protect yourself
against cross-site request forgery you
can verify the origin and the referrer
headers of HTTP requests to confirm they
actually come from your website these
can't be set programmatically in
browsers by JavaScript these are not
these can be faked using other methods
so they're not always a surefire way of
protecting against every single attack
you can use also use synchronizer tokens
or CSRF tokens to verify requests have
actually come from a real form on your
website these tokens are long
unpredictable unique data that's
generated on your server and placed into
web forms for submission with form data
your server then only accepts a request
from a user if it includes a recent
token that's been generated for that
user these tokens aren't stored in
cookies they're stored in the mark-up of
your website so they can't be sent in a
CSRF attack you can also use cookie to
header tokens which are very similar
these relies on JavaScript same origin
protocol
that means that JavaScript can only set
HTTP headers for sites that's hosted on
the same origin finally this is
absolutely no defense if your site has
been compromised in any other way for
example using cross-site scripting which
we're going to get onto next
[Applause]
how much did you would you be if I
change this right now
let's talk about bbcode bbcode was a
special language that allowed you to
format text on forums and in your posts
you could use it to insert images or
gifts of your favorite character it was
intended to be a replacement for HTML
and a subset a smaller reduced language
because validating HTML is a hard job so
having a reduced language would make it
easier to validate you could use it
insert your favorite gifts to your
heart's content and this was our idea
phone back on early web one day one of
my phone's friends found that
mismatching the opening and closing tags
BB code tags allowed you to do some
weird stuff mismatching tags confused
the BB code transcoder and caused broken
HTML to be inserted into that page from
there they were able to insert arbitrary
code into their posts and start
executing JavaScript they use this to
repeatedly spam the forum of a rival
online game clan during a match with
their opponents distracted they won the
match while their forms were slowly
filling up with gobbledygook this attack
allows someone to run their code on your
website which is otherwise known as
cross-site scripting this is Samy Kamkar
in 2005 he became famous for having
friends lots and lots and lots of
friends he wrote a1 which is a
self-replicating script that replicates
itself across the website what lots of
people in 2005 Samy had a MySpace page
and myspace was a limited social network
by today's standards you could customize
your headline but you couldn't really
put much in there
it was very restricted I had limited
formatting options and allowed you to
put 12 profile photos on your page but
only 12 if you wanted to add more photos
he had to take some down so sir me
discovered that some tags like the div
tag and the image tag were allowed to be
inserted into comp into content but the
script tag to insert JavaScript was
filtered myspace wasn't allowed wasn't
about to let people insert scripts and
run JavaScript on their pages myspace
stripped the screen I've okay sounds
back that some browsers executed
JavaScript install tax it's like the
browser's said here's a div tag do you
want to set a background yeah sure what
URL do you want to set oh I'll have
JavaScript please yeah sure I'll execute
that so myspace strict word JavaScript
porting injection and of injection of
scripts into MySpace pages it turns out
though that if you inserted a line break
into the words JavaScript the code would
run absolutely fine and myspace would
not know this house Sammy got JavaScript
into my space now he tried to write a
script that would replicate itself
across all the pages so you could find
out new friends by inspecting the pages
source so you could find the user IDs of
the people that you wanted to pad to do
this normally you would use the body dot
inner HTML property myspace filtered
this too they were prepared for people
like some incoming this isn't a problem
if you concatenate a string and evaluate
it using the eval function there's a
very good word buy a lot of there's
really good reason why a lot of
developers call eval evil
this trick also works on xml httprequest
onreadystatechange otherwise known as
ajax and this allowed sami to make HTTP
requests to the myspace api so he could
send friend requests sami also found
that myspace is api worked on a
different subdomain the same origin
protocol and browsers forbid him from
sending requests from the profile pages
domain but he discovered that you could
actually view profile pages on the api's
domain so he just redirected the browser
to the other domain and it worked fun
this is the complete code there's a few
more tricks that Samy used but I've
shown you the most interesting ones he
added this to his profile page and he
waited one hour later he had a new
friend request starting to work seven
hours later he had 221 friend requests
and it's starting to take off one hour
later that number has doubled to 480 is
starting to grow exponentially every
friend that he recruits that also
recruits all of their friends as well
and the total friend count grows and
grows and grows eight hours later Sammy
has nine hundred thousand friend
depressed s-- is now growing so fast
that every time Sammy refreshes the page
thousands more people are being added to
that count
this is Sammy's actual screenshot
showing the number of friend of Christ's
one hour later myspace collapses under
the load of people requesting to be Sam
his friend
my space eventually recovered and
patched the vulnerability two hours
later Sammy was raided by the US Secret
Service he was sentenced to 90 days
community service he was only allowed
the use of one computer and not allowed
to use the Internet and he was ordered
to pay over $15,000 restitution to
myspace cross-site scripting allows
users to inject that own code into your
site and some people believe content
injection is a better word for this
because it's people stuffing their own
HTML their own CSS their own images into
your site and it's very dangerous so how
can you help protect yourself from
cross-site scripting you can escape user
input using our on entry using a library
like lip out like Santa HTML don't be
attempted to roll your own myspace were
prepared for people like Sammi and they
weren't prepared enough this is really
really difficult to do use an auto
escaping libraries such as react or
angular or a templating library
they won't save you on their on their
own and that are ways around them but
they can be updated frequently and they
are very convenient to use you can
implement a content security policy this
restricts which domains content can be
securely loaded from loading content
from third parties is very very risky so
you want to lock it down to domains that
you absolutely trust you can also use
the integrity property on script and
link tags this allows you to insert a
hash into these tags and this hash is
like a fingerprint for the resources
that you're loading if the resource
changes if it's being changed by someone
else in the manner in the middle of the
tag that fingerprint will also change as
well so if the fingerprint doesn't match
the resource then the browser's can
refuse to load it
in 1999 the web was like Wild West
Frontier these newly discovered attacks
could be used against pretty much all
websites and it was just utter chaos
this is the picture that we still
conjure about web security and about the
web and the truth is the stakes are
higher than they ever they've ever been
now this is not just discussing your
favorite characters we're now talking
about personal data we're talking about
people's money and people's lives but I
also believe that there's never been a
better time to learn about web security
more and more resources and tools are
available to help you write secure code
and try not to think of it like a wild
rest but think about it as an adventure
playground
if you're curious learning about web
security can be really fun and really
really interesting and it need not be
really hard it's an important topic but
I'm really confident that there really
has never been a better time to learn
everyone has to start and everyone is a
beginner once so I want to shout out all
these people who helped make this talk
possible for telling me stories about
the early web names have been changed to
protect the innocent and the guilty
thank you very much
[Music]